but title of my talk is basically 10
commandments for efficiency as
architecture
and you might have noticed the star on
the 10 and that says conditions apply
which you know
you'll know that soon why it's there
so let me start by introducing myself
my name is kushagra god and
i am if known i am better known as
chinchang on web
and i'm from india now just to clarify
india is not just the land of snakes and
tigers
we recently started writing css also
okay uh i'm a front-end developer by
it's my day job and i work at a
wonderful startup called wingify so we
basically develop an av testing tool
called visual website optimizer that i
work on
and uh in case you have already heard
about me it is probably due to my open
source projects or
one of which is hind.css is basically a
css tooltip library and the second one
is a pixel art that lets you create
pixel art using css
right so what is this talk gonna be
about
uh
so i've been
uh doing front-end stuff for almost
three years now and like we all do i
have learned a lot about issues we face
in css and many solutions that we can
use to prevent them and avoid them
so this is going to be about those css
stuff that i would like to share with
you from my experience
and
the target of the stock is to basically
help us uh
know certain things which make the css
architecture efficient and by efficient
i mean two things over here so uh first
your css will be easy should be easy to
understand for you as well as anyone uh
new joining on your project
and also it should be easy to extend in
future
so no more careless style sprinkling
which generally uh tends to be in our
apps
also i'm a first-time speaker at a
conference and that to such a big
conference and it's quite hard
and i'm not really good at speaking and
making presentations
so uh i i'm basically added a game for
some reason uh because i'm good at
making games
and this is a game which we can all play
together at the end of the talk
all right so commandment number one it
says uh thy height shall remain greater
than thy files at all times
it simply means keep your file sizes
small
but why why do we need to make our file
sizes small so first thing it helps to
keep your code module and modular code
basically means uh whenever you need to
add something or you need to change
something you can quickly search for it
at the uh you can search for the target
spot
where in the code you actually need to
place your css because uh modularity
will
easily enable you to figure out which
file
or which module actually needs to be
changed
so things become quite fast in
extensibility wise and what do we need
to do it's a simple rule keep dividing
and refactoring your files as in when
they get too big so you just need to
stop at points in your development and
see what uh could be separated out into
separate modules and just keep on doing
it periodically
so uh let's take a sample scenario uh
when you
you're starting a side project on the
first day of christmas
and obviously you start with a single
css file a style of css as that is
commonly known for
uh for a single file and you place all
your css in
just a single file right and you quickly
uh recognize and apply the rule that my
style.css is getting bigger and i need
to refactor it and separate it out into
modules so on the fourth day of
christmas you realize that and
this is a common scenario which applies
to almost every app so you could
separate your style.css file into say
four
separate files or modules so base could
have styles pertaining to tags uh anchor
tags and
other tags which need to have a basic
style then there could be a helpers.css
which is basically helpers like uh
for helper for floating elements left
and right or say clearing floats then
there could be a file called
component.css which could carry your
components like buttons dropdowns tabs
and all
then there could be an optional
theme.css let's say you have your
site which renders in a blue theme and
also there's a red theme so maybe you
could have theme.css as well
and if you're having uh if you're using
a preprocessor like sas you might as
well have a file called mixing.css
which has your mix sense
further on the air day of christmas you
realize that your components.css again
got bigger
it has a lot of components in it so
again you apply the same rule you
basically divided and refactor into
separate modules so your component.css
now can become a folder basically
components and it can have files like
buttons.css dropdown.css basically every
component divided into a separate file
and if you follow this approach most
probably you will be happy on the 12th
day of christmas
okay commandment number two thy code
conflict shall remain at one place
and this basically means use variables
now this is uh
related to a preprocessor uh i mean a
preprocessor because this won't work in
css currently but the good news is that
variables are
arriving in native css in future as well
so you can always use that
in css also
so let's take a sample layout so this is
a very common layout into apps today so
basically have a header sidebar and
content so header is something that
spans full width and it has a height of
50 pixel then you have a sidebar that
spans the complete height and a width
fixed width and it's obviously starting
from the
bottom of header then there's content
which is below the header and alongside
the sidebar
now if you notice here there are too
many magic numbers and uh these are
hardcoded numbers which should be
avoided and we'll see why
so consider this approach
what basically i have done is i have
separated those hard coded magic numbers
into separate into variables
right so i have a variable called header
height which is 50 pixels and a sidebar
with
so what i'm doing right now is instead
of using those hard-coded numbers in my
code i'm actually using those variables
so uh
why is this better first of all it's
less error prone so we have uh
we have minimized the chance of making
mistakes so if i was using those
hard-coded numbers i might at some place
use wrong values instead of 10 i might
use 20 or
likewise so we have
potentially minimized the error here
and the second thing is easy
extensibility in future
why extensibility because let's say this
probably applies to early stages of
development where you need to tweak
things very quickly and see how it goes
so with this approach you can basically
tweak the variables instead of modifying
the values at every place in the code
and you can
very quickly see uh how the result is
and decide on the values and fix on them
okay commandment number three thou shalt
believe in abstractions
this simply means component abstraction
okay so uh let's take this example
where you have a game and you're
developing this in html5 just because
you can nowadays
and uh you are basically styling the
complete screen of the game
and specifically the hud elements you
see so let's take the example of the one
you see at the bottom
left and the
top right
so your code might look probably look
like this
you have a class for the stats hud
element called let's say it's a class
called hud stats
so uh it's a fixed position element on
the screen
and it has some opacity and filter to
just to give it a
feel
and obviously we position it using the
bottom bottom and left
similarly for the map hud element so
it's going to be same it's a fixed
position element the same filtering and
obviously the top and right
properties too just to position it
now if you notice here the first three
properties in both the
rules are exactly the same
and this is repetition
and
we all know repetition is bad
it's a common issue of common reason for
issues that you face in your
applications so we should not repeat it
so this is a different approach
what we have done here is we have
separated out those three properties
into a separate class and it's called
hud element
and
now hud stats and hud map which were
initial classes are just left with the
positioning styles
and actually these styles which were
different for those classes
and the usage is simple so we have a
html element now the thing is that both
the classes need to be applied so that
we get these styles from both the
classes
so this can
be improved further
let's say we are using a preprocessor
so uh there's something called
specifically inside there's something
called placeholders so uh the difference
in from the previous slide is that we
now define a placeholder instead of a
class which basically defines uh
those properties which are common in
those hud elements
and instead of uh basically using that
placeholder we extend our current
classes with that
right so what it enables is basically
hud stats and hud map classes are now
extended with the hud element
placeholders and now i can simply use
the individual class in my html i don't
have to repeat the two classes
so no repetition here
clean code
less chances of error right
commandment number four thou shall speak
spread peace and stop thy selectors from
fighting
any guesses for this
keep selector strength slow
so selectors have strengths and they do
fight we have all seen this in christian
stock so
selectors have something called as
specificity
which determines the strength of those
selectors and they do conflict with each
other let's take a simple example let's
say we have a component of tabs in our
app and for some reason a developer
styled it using div dot tabs
and it was being used in the html we
simply put the class
now another developer joined the project
and
he
he was required to make a variation of
the tab component which instead of
having a full width which initial class
has it was required to have a half width
50 width so he went ahead and made a
separate class for that tabs half and
gave it a property with 50
and this was meant to be used with along
with the tabs class so this is a simple
common usage how he would go about have
the tabs class on the element and along
with it he has the tabs half now this
won't work
and the reason is simple the strength of
the first selector which is div dot tabs
is basically greater than the selector
defined uh
after it which is tabs half
and the reason is because of
concatenation
so
concatenation of the actual tag with the
class increases the strength and hence
the second class is not able to override
the properties of first class
things can get a lot messier from here
so a probable solution is you again
prefix your class name with the div tag
just to make your selectives equal with
the first one and able to override the
first one
right or you could go the
better way not important
plus we have another problem now the
tabs can only be used on the with along
with a div tag so it's uh it is fine but
uh it's an unnecessary unnecessary
restriction you have put on your
selector that even in future if you
decide to have the tab class on some
other element this won't work it would
break
so the solution is simple here
there was no need to concatenate the tab
component the tab class with dev we
could simply have dot tabs
and this would be solved
so the key thing is just keep your
selectors low
don't put unnecessary nesting don't put
unnecessary concatenation because that
would just make things worse
okay over to commandment number five
thou shalt treat your classes as thy own
children name them with equal love
is basically naming convention
okay so
naming is very important in css i feel
and when i say it's important in css i i
actually mean not in css itself but in
comparison to other languages
because if you see in other languages
if your variable names are not correct
they don't make sense they are not
i mean they are not good nothing would
break your code would still function
everything will work fine but css has
some
bad things in it
like the earlier commandment we saw
selector strengths sector specificity so
these things are
something which can be avoided if we
incorporate a very good naming system in
our css and that is why i say it is very
important in css
so bem is something i'm going to talk
about
as a naming
convention so bem basically uh is a
methodology to uh
not to name things but instead uh
to separate out components from your app
it basically supports component
abstraction so bem stands for block
element and modifier so what it says
that uh in your app you
most probably have things which are
independent uh
independent components things which
could be separated out into modules and
could be used uh anywhere independently
so uh them cons uh terms them as block
so block is basically a component you
have in your app then there is something
called element so element is sub parts
of your component a component might have
several things which
eventually build up to the component so
those are called elements
then finally this modifier a component
might have variations which bam terms as
modifier
so this is the methodology part of bim
but this is
augmented with a naming convention as
well
so the naming convention i have shown
here is basically a variation of actual
thing which was developed at yandex so
it's a
variation by nicholas and harry roberts
so
what we translate this into is a block
is always a single class rule number one
so let's say we have a class called
component so block is a component then
there's an element class so element
class according to this rule is
basically uh prefixing
with the actual component name and
double underscores
and lastly we have the modifier which is
uh
whose name we get by prefixing component
name and then double hyphens
so this is the naming convention we
follow for all the three elements
three parts of them
now let's see how this applies actually
and why it's good
so let's take an example of a component
because then basically uh works on
component we have a slider in our app
and uh
if if you were not to use bem this was
the um probably the css you would have
written so we have the slider class
which has a position relative then we
have
two things residing in the slider so
first is this slider track so we
write a css when the cycle track is
inside the slider we give it a
background and similarly for the knob
right and you might as well have a
variation of this slider a variation in
which we have an extra input to
basically uh
manually let the user manually change
the values so for for that we might have
a selector like this
so uh
if you see here we have lots of uh
so called the bad things in css in our
selectors
so the first first
selector is fine but the second selector
has nesting in it the third as well
and uh the last one is quite uh
terrible so we have concatenation along
with nesting so that is really bad
so let's apply bem on this example
so uh if you were to use the same naming
conventions we just saw
this would actually translate into the
component class being the same slider
the slider track
would be simply named as the component
name underscore underscore the actual
element so these are the elements track
and off the slider now track and slider
knob then the variation so variation
would actually be a
style like a slider hyphen iphone with
input and whenever this variation class
is basically on a component we need to
actually display the slider input which
is again an element of a component so if
you notice here
uh first selector remains the same but
the second and third selector we have
managed to remove the
nesting so they are single classes now
much better much uniform and less
specific and even in the last one we
have
the nesting is still there but
concatenation has been removed much
better than the previous one
so this is how bem can be used to
actually keep your selectors low uh the
target is to keep this uh every selector
as just one class wherever it works
okay commandment number six
thou shall not mix up the ego and z
indexes
z index management
so what's the issue with z indexes
so uh
this is a common thing we see
in most of our apps so people tend to
set properties set the values of the
indexes properties like
999 99999 and the reason is simple they
don't know what might come over me so
why not set a max value
so the solution for this
is basically uh
using the commandment number two which
we saw earlier using variables and
separating out your z indexes in two
variables right so uh let's say we have
an app and it has multiple components so
components like overlay slide out
backdrop then there is a slide out
there's a sidebar navigation header and
stuff
so uh first thing we separate our
indexes into variables but that is not
it so
what additional purpose this code is
solving is it's basically translating
your visual hierarchy the actual layer
system of your components into code now
i have i have a linear
uh representation of your layers right
in my code
what good good is it
so uh there are two things you could do
with your components in with your ui
elements in your app you could change uh
the existing
layer position of those elements or you
might add new elements ui elements to
your app so changing existing z indexes
become really easy because you actually
know what might break you actually know
the
what things come before me and what
after me
and same with the z uh while adding new
elements to your app you actually you
can uh
now actually visualize where my element
fits in the layer system right
so no more z index 99999 you can keep
yours indexes short because now you know
what's above me and what's below me
okay over to commandment number seven
inheritance doesn't always gives you the
money
so uh this is again a sas commandment
and it basically
is about the ad extent thing which sas
provides so like you saw earlier at
extend is something which you can use to
extend a current class with any previous
class and the properties of that class
which you actually extend would be um
carried over to your new class right so
uh ad extent has a
a thing which
which might
make your css very bad and i term it as
selector hell
let's see what it is
so let's say in your app you have a
an error class which is basically
used to define things which any error in
your app might have so uh your error
should be
colored red and it might have a
background a reddish background so
anything which is which represents error
would obviously be using this error
class
then there was a requirement to actually
uh
increase the padding let's say of any
error which is coming in the sidebar so
we probably will have a style like that
any error in the sidebar should be
having a padding of 10 pixels
now consider we have a notification box
and it's basically an error notification
box so what i would do is my error
notification
should extend with
error class so i get the error
properties on myself without actually
writing the properties again
now notice this
this is the compiled css of the sas over
here and if you notice the highlighted
selector is something which we did not
wanted and did not actually
intentionally write but it is being
generated and this is an unnecessary css
so this might look a not so much of
concern right now but if you let's say
you have a huge app with so many styles
this is something you could end up with
and uh this is
a real
selector
we had in our app
so the solution for this is basically
using placeholders which we earlier saw
in component extract
commandment
so uh
what we're doing differently here is
first of all the error class
does not have the properties now is
basically transferred into a placeholder
so we define a new placeholder called
error and that now has the properties of
an error
second rule we never extend a class we
always extend a placeholder
so uh
error class is something that is to be
used in the html so we create the error
class and then basically extend it with
the placeholder similarly we had the
message notification so that is
extending the error again
and rule number three three whenever a
class needs to be tweaked
uh based on some location or based on
some anything so we use class for that
and that you can see so uh
while doing the padding of the error
error we basically use the class there
and if you follow those three rules you
see that
that unnecessary css that was generated
is no more there
and this actually helps reducing
compilation time as well
and in our app we were able to reduce it
by 76 percent because sas needs to do a
lot of work to uh while compilation to
actually see
what is extending being extended where
in your code and replace those instances
so it's a lot of work
this could really be
of
quite a benefit
this is what that star meant
so uh seven commandments is all i have
and uh now i'll be actually
switching over to the game which i was
talking about
so this game is basically a mmo
ctg so that's massively multiplayer
online css throwing game
so if you could open this ip in your
mobiles or laptops we could all play
this together
so the thing here is
i don't play this you guys play it
together so if anything goes wrong it is
because because of you or me
so uh we are getting a count here uh the
number of people who are getting
connected to the game
so nine people
please don't start sending things
let me explain what it does
okay so uh
so this
uh let's see uh what we need to do here
so i'm starting a sample level here
level three is
guys where's the code of conduct please
so uh this is level number three it's
quite hard so i'm using it as a demo
level so we have a player here and
that's a flag
which we need to
uh
basically get and there's a block in
between which we need to somehow remove
right now all uh you guys what you need
to do is uh you you all see a text box
right
it's all good
so you'd see a text box where you need
to put a pair a property or a value
right so let's say display colon none
and you need to submit submit that right
and uh
the thing here is this is a sample
scenario whatever rule you submit
whatever property and value you submit
is basically gonna apply uh in an
abstract way on the scenario not really
getting applied uh technically but
guys you won't be able to grill like
this
so uh
can we try uh submitting sensible
solutions
this is a css contract
so uh
let me give you a hint here so you all
every one of you is basically in front
of a table
and this is a border which is blocking
so if you are
in front of a table and there is a
border how do you remove the border
oh no solution
something related to border and table
okay so solution here was
i guess nobody is making
and current attempt
so the solution is basically uh border
collapse collapse so if you do that it
basically will disappear the
border so let's try this level one
so that's an enemy it keeps on hitting
us
oh my god
so you need to submit a
property and a value pair that would
basically somehow block this enemy from
hitting us
can we try this
okay i think i need to give a hint here
as well
so you basically uh
need something in between the player and
the enemy
probably a block so how do you display a
block
can we try submitting correct solutions
vendor prefixes are not required
so uh another thing which i forgot to
mention is if 50 of the audience submits
the correct solution this level would
get cleared
and out of 103 we just
have 17 correct solutions come on css
lovers
i don't think we are going to reach 50
percent correct solutions
okay solution for this is obvious so
people are sending display block so
assuming 50 audience was not doing funny
stuff
oh see
so
so we would have a block which would
actually kill the enemy and level clear
so this is interesting one last level
from my side
level two so the player is on a platform
and he needs to capture the flag but the
issue is the platforms are not on safe
same level so i'm not able to get the
flag
so how do you get uh something which has
broken on the next line to actually get
on the same level as the previous
element
come on
not a single right solution
okay so the solution is basically white
space no wrap so
and we
clear it yep
that's it from my site thanks for
listening
hi um and
pretty much
the beginning of your talk you
talked about keeping your files modular
and small right
um
but you mentioned it's in css and then
you mentioned that if you're using sas
you should use the mixens file for sets
right don't you think that if you're
using sas you should keep small files
but then concatenate them into one css
file
when you deploy
so production is not really of a concern
here
so it's a good practice even to get your
all your styles into single css so you
don't have uh
i mean multiple
http requests being sent from the
browser so that is something which is
fine the concern here is actually in the
development process
why you need modularity is because you
need to append things and change things
over time right so spreading off files
is necessary in development not in
production i guess
okay i have another small question um
you showed that your
um separating it to files according to
this
kind of the style of the components like
drop-downs and stuff like that right
don't you think that maybe also it would
be good to separate it to
the pages that you're using or the
templates
that are associated with most of these
styles because a lot of times styles are
associated more with
the page
they appear on and not with a specific
component right so uh so uh
writing styles pertaining to specific
pages is something we all have been
doing uh for a long time now uh but the
issue with that is uh
uh it leads to basically a lot of
repetitive code
and code gets repeated on different
pages
and even though certain things are same
on all the pages you still have repeated
code so the solution for this which many
people have started using
is to have a different uh outlook over
this so instead of styling things on
specific pages again and again you
basically uh
what you do is uh look out for things
which are common in all the pages and
separate them as components so that is
reason number one i have i haven't
included those page styles in the uh
sample solution i uh
just
showed
so uh you basically should have
components in your app rather than
styling pages but even if you have those
specific page styling things even if
there's a requirement you can always
have something called as a specific page
section where you have
styles for your home page your for your
about page and stuff
okay thanks um
um actually i'm wondering about the
point number five you mentioned about
the
instead of using the uh nested uh
selector you trying to prefix and using
the name convention using uh underscore
on that dash right and i'm wondering if
if we make the codeless reusable because
i mean every time you need to prefix i
mean
the name with some of the
outer class name
and
i mean
after a while maybe the name will be
blow up and it becomes very long and
the code is left reusable
so i agree these selectors do get do
tend to get longer if you
use the bim convention but i feel the
extensibility and
the uh
and the reusability and the uh thing
that it lets you avoid very of various
things in css like character sense and
all is much more
than just the names getting bigger it
doesn't really affect affect you it's
just a visual thing that you uh see long
selectors and that really scares you
so i guess the
advantages are better more than the
disadvantages in that case uh hello uh
great job uh what's what do you think is
the advantage of using placeholder if
you compare it to like variables
so placeholder and variables are i guess
two separate things so variables can
like in other languages to
store values right they could be single
decimal strings and maps and stuff but
placeholders on the other hand are
something which is a group of properties
just like classes are or any other rule
is so it's a group of property which you
can extend variables is not something
you can extend placeholders can be
extended